Lagertha from Vikings is one of the most
iconic warrior women
in television history.
Millions watched her lead armies, divorce
Ragnar and rule as Queen.
The show's creators said they
based her on real medieval sources. So I
read those sources. The
actual medieval account
written 400 years after the Viking Age
ended by a Christian cleric with an
agenda. And it tells
a completely different story than what
made it to the screen.
The show makes female Viking
warriors look uncommon but accepted. The
medieval source presents
Lagertha as proof that pagan
society was barbaric. And modern
archaeologists just found a female
warrior grave that's forcing
historians to rethink everything. So
which version is true? In the show
Lagertha is Ragnar's first
wife. A shield maiden who fights in the
shield wall. She divorces
Ragnar, becomes Earl, then Queen.
The medieval source: Lagertha tests Ragnar
by making him fight a
bear and a dog. He divorces
her because she tried to kill him with
those animals. She later
murders her second husband
with a spearhead hidden in her dress. One
of these is fiction. The
other one is closer to reality.
Let me show you which one. Vikings
premiered in 2013. Lagertha,
played by Catherine Winnick,
became the breakout character. She's
portrayed as Ragnar's equal.
She fights in the shield wall
during the first raid on England. When
Ragnar takes his second wife, she divorces
him. She becomes Earl
of Hedeby, later Queen of Kattegat. The
show treats her warrior
status as uncommon but not
shocking. Men respect her combat skills.
She is a political leader
who happens to be female.
Articles called her the most powerful
woman on television. She
became a symbol of female
empowerment. They based her on a medieval
text called the Gesta
Danorum. So what does that text
actually say? The Gesta Danorum, Deeds of
the Danes, was written
around 1200 by Saxo Grammaticus.
He worked for the Archbishop of Lund and
wrote to glorify Danish Christian kings.
That's roughly 200 years
after the Viking Age ended. Imagine
someone today writing about the
1800s based entirely on oral tradition.
That's the gap we're
dealing with. According to Saxo,
Lagertha first appears when Norwegian
noblewomen grabbed weapons to defend
themselves. He describes
her as "a skilled Amazon who, though a
maiden, had the courage of a
man." Notice that phrasing.
Not "she was courageous." She had the
courage of a man. Her
gender is the scandalous part.
After the battle, Ragnar sends messengers
to court her. But
Lagertha tests him. She places
a bear and a dog at her home's entrance.
Ragnar has to kill them
both. He thrust one through with
a spear and caught the other one by the
throat, wrung its neck and
choked it. If that sounds more
like a fairy tale than history, hold that
thought. They marry and
have three children. They live
happily until Ragnar gets bored, starts
raiding again, and meets
another woman. He divorces Lagertha to
marry Tora. This is
where it gets wild. Years later, Ragnar
faces rebellion. Lagertha
shows up with 120 ships to help him. They
win the battle. But
instead of reconciling,
Lagertha goes home and murders her second
husband with a spear tip
hidden in her dress. She takes his lands.
She becomes a ruling Queen.
This is supposed to be history. But does
any of this sound real to you? The
fighting bears and dogs,
the hidden spearhead, the 120 ships. These
are fairy tale tropes.
Saxo was a 12th century Christian cleric
writing propaganda. His goal
was to make pre-Christian
Scandinavia look barbaric. How better to
show that than to write
about women warriors? To Saxo's medieval
Christian audience, a woman
who fights is unnatural, savage.
Look at his phrasing again.
"Though a maiden, had the courage of a
man." She's only admirable
because she acts like a man.
He's reinforcing gender hierarchy. This
isn't history. It's a
smear campaign wrapped in an adventure
story. And scholars know this.
Modern historians call the Gesta Danorum
legendary. Part myth, part folklore, part
religious agenda. So where
did Saxo get Lagertha from? The most
likely source? A Norse
goddess named Thorgerd Holgabrud.
Thorgerd was a protective deity.
Warriors prayed to her before battle. In
the sagas, she appears as
a fierce, armed woman. Saxo probably took
this pagan goddess, stripped
her divinity, and turned her
into a mortal woman to make her more
grounded. Then he added Amazon
tropes from classical literature.
Medieval writers loved mixing Norse myths
with Greek ideas. The result? A character
who's part goddess, part
myth, part propaganda. That's not history.
So if both the TV show
and the medieval source are fiction, does
that mean Viking women never
fought? No. And this is where it gets
interesting. In 2017, a discovery rocked
the academic world. Grave Bj.581
from Birka, Sweden.
This grave was excavated in the 1880s. The
skeleton was buried with
a full military kit: a sword, an axe, a
knife, two shields, two
spears, 25 arrows, and two horses.
Plus a full set of gaming pieces,
the kind military strategists used to plan
battles. For over 100 years, scholars
assumed this was a male warrior. Standard
stuff. Then in 2017,
researchers ran DNA tests.
The skeleton was female. The backlash was
immediate. Critics argued
the weapons were symbolic,
maybe a status marker, not proof of
combat. But the researchers
pointed to the gaming pieces. Those weren't
decorative. They were tools
for military planning. This wasn't just a
warrior. This was a strategist,
possibly a commander. And she's not
alone. Archaeologists have
found about a dozen other Viking-age
women buried with weapons. In Kaupang,
Norway, two women in a
boat grave with spears. In Gerdrup,
Denmark, a woman with a
spearhead. In Klinta, Sweden,
a woman's cremation grave with an axe.
But here's the catch: every
single grave is debatable.
An axe could be for chopping firewood, a
domestic tool. That spear
could be a ritual magic staff, not a weapon.
Scholars have argued about these graves for
decades. Were these women warriors,
or were the weapons symbolic? But Birka
is different. This
wasn't a single axe or a
debatable spear. This was a sword, an
axe, a knife, two spears,
two shields, 25 arrows, horses,
and a full set of gaming pieces. If this
burial was just symbolic of family status,
they committed hard to the bit. So what's
the actual truth about Lagertha? The TV show?
About 80% fiction. It borrowed Lagertha's
name and the concept, then
invented almost everything else. The medieval
source? Also fiction, just older fiction.
Written two centuries later by
a Christian cleric using warrior women as
propaganda. Lagertha
was probably mythological,
based on the goddess Thorgerd mixed with
Amazon stories, filtered
through religious bias. But
the archaeology? That's real. The Birka
grave proves at least one
Viking woman held warrior status in the
10th century. Viking women
had more legal rights than
most medieval European women.
Some probably learned weapon skills. And
at least one was buried
like a military commander.
But Viking society was still patriarchal.
Warfare was primarily male.
The fact that Saxo wrote about
Lagertha at all suggests she was
remarkable because she was unusual. So
here's the uncomfortable reality.
Lagertha was probably just a
story medieval Christians
told about pagan ancestors,
filtered through biases, mixed with
mythology, shaped by propaganda. But
here's what matters.
At least one Viking woman held warrior
status. At least one was
buried with the honors of a military
strategist. The TV show got that
part right, even if
everything else was fiction.
The truth is messier than Hollywood, and
honestly, that makes it more interesting.
If you are here for the history without
the bullshit, hit
subscribe. Every week I break
down what really happened and what we
just wished it. I'll
see you in the next one.